so earlier in the show we were talking
about skeletons and how their terrifying
body would uh
well what's even more terrifying is
there's an olympic sport called the
skeleton which is a headfirst luge i
don't know if you guys have seen the
skeleton event it's terrifying and
before i got uh before the olympics i
got to talk to a skeleton racer who
actually ended up having a pretty rough
time in sochi but who cares he's still
an incredible athlete and he's in way
better shape than i'll ever be and he's
an awesome dude his name is john daly
let's take a look
this is incredible this is john daly
everybody and you are our first
skeleton skeleton skeletons did you say
skeleton act exactly oh skeleton
happened to keep going
why is skeleton racing different from
say the luge
we get to go head first and i think we
are better looking
and you want your best looking part yes
to go over there i think that's how
they're going to pick the team this year
don't you want to be a little bit
more compact if you're going to
no you want to be taller actually really
yeah because then you can be more
aerodynamic i'm more aerodynamic than
you yes because you could be you could
weigh more and still be sleek this is
the the sport for me you want to be tall
and a little bit doughy yeah well
there's some vibration dampening there
then right you can't call it jelly
this is a whole new way to look at the
world cup is half full you know yes it
is with milkshake
but why would you want to go face first
that's like you know where your brain is
and your eyeballs pretty much everything
of vital importance that's true i mean i
get i get like a helmet and like a
couple layers of hair gel so yeah two
ways to protect it can i touch it of
course it moves a little bit
that's the right amount of give it is
just enough would you wear that shirt
under your
i would wear nothing really yeah in the
buff in the buff skin to win skin to win
skin to win yeah
skin away skin to win next time i have a
female suitor i'm going to say that
before i flick the lights off
it's getting the wheel i think she's
gone i just hear the window open why is
it called skeleton racing it's the
skeleton frame of a bobsled oh i thought
it was because like pirates did it or
it's deadly well see that would be a lot
better this is going to be on tv let's
start that rumor okay pirates used to
seize your land
freeze it with their cunning
and then go face first losing looking
for a scurvy for scurvy for lemons so
they don't get scurvy that's why it's
called squirrely because they love the
curvy as is written on the back of most
maps which are always burned around the
edges is it hard to drive the speed
limit when you outside of a car go 90
miles an hour yes if you ever get pulled
over have you considered saying like hi
i'm a human bullet give me a break yeah
so that's if i stop would you like to
start the nickname the human bullet i
would love that nickname john the human
bullet daily it's a lot better than my
old one what is it jmfd jmfd yes what is
that like i can't tell you a pure cut of
ecstasy
what is it jmfd yes oh john
daily yes you can say that
but i can't sure you can this is on
midnight perfect give it a try
balls balls
dickballs
in the dickballs
them in the dickballs
rolls right off the top i mean if you
win a race and they and you get up and
they give you the medal if you hold it
in the sky and go
in the dick balls i'll give you a
hundred thousand dollars did you go to
college i did did you major in risking
at all now the best six years of my life
though really what did you study public
relations advertising public relations
and advertising yeah i don't know what
i'm gonna do with that i'll have to make
a decision sooner or later but you could
be don draper you do advertising you'd
be like look gillette it's the most
refreshing shave and i know because i've
been face first and luge you know like
pirates that's right that is where the
scurvy rhyme comes from most of the maps
are burned around the edge so do we have
the account then we widen a reveal
you're just in an alley talking to a
pigeon
john
i sincerely mean it when i say you're
incredible hilarious gregarious
and you know what in your heart you're
about 11 feet tall
thank you